[Music]
foreign
Google Cloud's truly unified batch and
streaming data processing product is now
even better
well that's exactly what I'm saying
introducing dataflow Prime the next
generation of dataflow with vertical
Auto scaling and right fitting which
provide automatic fine-tuning of memory
and Stage specific resource allocation
so you have fewer things to worry about
plus a new pricing model to simplify
your billing
these new features help to optimize
resource utilization remediate
out-of-memory issues and provide more
predictable pricing come along as we
discover how dataflow Prime will improve
your processing experience and help you
better go with the flow
if you're new to dataflow check out the
video in the description that gives more
context on what dataflow is and how it
works
when running jobs on dataflow classic
you have to think about worker type and
predict compute resources for each job
if you know the future predicting
resources is easy but for the rest of us
it takes time effort and failures with
sometimes multiple retries to figure out
the right combination of computational
resources to run an efficient Pipeline
and avoid having out-of-memory issues
traditionally you can select a worker
type and data flow creates a network of
identical workers called a worker pool
to do data processing there is one pool
and these resources are fixed if you run
out of memory you have to stop the job
and rerun it manually with workers with
more memory capacity
this can lead to your pipeline being
stuck increasing backlog and overall
creating a less than ideal user
experience
if only there were some way to
automatically increase the memory
capacity of workers oh
what's this vertical Auto scaling with
data flow Prime with vertical Auto
scaling dataflow Prime will upscale or
downscale workers memory capacity
without any human intervention
memory is automatically tuned to meet
the requirements for your job and is
dynamically adapted to these needs as
the requirements change so you as a user
no longer have to specify a worker type
or try to be a psychic when doing your
job dataflow Prime does it for you this
greatly improves productivity since
you're not running into filled jobs due
to out of memory issues and because the
memory tuning is automatically handled
it frees up space in your brain for
other important things
plus your pipelines are more efficient
enabling you to build scalable pipelines
with real-time data let's look at a
visual example here we have four workers
with four gigabytes of memory capacity
and during a run two workers show out of
memory errors vertical Auto scaling
replaces all of the workers with new
workers that have a larger capacity in
this case six gigabytes
what if that's still not enough
well upscaling can happen iteratively so
if the new upskilled capacity is still
not sufficient to get the job done it
will upscale again in this case to
workers with eight gigabytes and the
same goes for downscaling so you're not
paying for a capacity that you don't
need
there are default upscaling and
downscaling limits but you can go beyond
these limits by using resource hints
check out the link in the description
for documentation on how to do this
pair vertical Auto scaling with
horizontal Auto scaling a current data
flow feature and its power multiplies
horizontal Auto scaling automatically
scales the number of workers up or down
based on your job requirement
now you have a powerful automated
platform that can upscale and downscale
worker numbers and worker memory without
you having to intervene
this automatically Builds an optimized
compute mesh with more machines and
bigger machines that is customized based
on your data processing needs leaving
your pipeline to flow easily
now that we've covered vertical Auto
scaling let's move on this next feature
will have you using your resources in a
much more optimized way
as I touched on before when running a
job on dataflow classic there's one
worker pool for each dataflow job and
any stage of your pipeline can run on
any worker from that work or pool
however different stages of your
pipeline may have different resource
requirements for example one stage of
your pipeline may need higher memory
than another and running these two
stages under the same resource
constraints can result in resources
being over or underutilized
this is where our second new feature
right fitting fits in
with right fitting dataflow Prime
creates multiple worker pools each with
a resource configuration that fits the
requirements of your transforms this
allows you to run different transforms
on different worker pools which are
customized specifically for those
transforms
you can specify the worker resources
using resource hints for either the
entire pipeline or for a specific stage
in the pipeline so you can use resource
hints like GPU and RAM and execute
different stages of your pipeline on
different worker pools with the right
resources
this means that I can now have two pools
one for stage one with eight gigabyte
workers and the other for stage two
which needs less memory with four
gigabyte workers this lowers cost
because you're not running everything on
a worker that is over or under
provisioned which helps you improve
efficiency and avoid performance
bottlenecks
let's go through another visual example
this time using gpus
with dataflow classic if you need to use
gpus to do data processing gpus are
attached to all the workers in the
worker pool even if only some workers
will process the stage that needs gpus
with right fitting on dataflow Prime
different stages can be processed by
different worker pools so if you have a
data Pipeline and one stage needs gpus
you have the flexibility to ask data
flow using resource hints to run just
that stage on a worker with gpus while
the rest of the stages can continue
running on regular workers this means no
wasted GPU resources and less cost to
you
once again when combined with horizontal
Auto scaling which automatically scales
the number of workers up or down you get
a lot more power this allows you to
independently scale each worker pool up
or down to get the right fit for the job
what will we do with all this free time
before we move on let's recap our two
new features vertical Auto scaling is
based on memory usage it automatically
up and down scales worker memory to the
requirements of the job freeing up your
time improving productivity and keeping
your pipeline flowing
right fitting is based on tuning worker
resources it allows you to run different
stages of your pipeline on different
worker Pools by using resource hints
allowing you the flexibility to use
specific workers for specific stages so
they're used as optimally as possible
now let's talk about pricing we've
developed a simplified pricing model
that makes it easier to understand and
predict your data processing cost on
dataflow Prime the dataflow classic
pricing model charges users for multiple
resources each of these resources are
charged separately and have different
pricing dataflow Prime provides a new
simplified model where all the compute
resources are Blended together and you
are charged based on the amount of data
compute units dcus that your job uses
dcus are a metric that tracks the amount
of compute resources that are used by
your job one DCU is comparable to the
compute resources used by a data flow
job that runs for one hour using one
worker with one bcpu and four gigabytes
of memory this is much easier to
understand calculate track and predict
when you're wondering how many resources
your job will consume you now only have
to consider dcus and other resources
versus several resources you had to
consider before of course the higher the
number of compute resources your job
uses and the longer the job runs the
more dcus you'll consume check out the
pricing page linked in the description
to see how much each DCU costs for your
job type and region
if you'd like to know more about
dataflow prime check out the product
page and other links listed in the
description below if you're already
using dataflow check out dataflow Prime
and let us know what you think and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]